うっすらなやっぱ微妙に違うな
わかんないあんまりでも日焼けしなかったね
金ちゃん初めてそうです思ってリアの10期に分かれてなかったですね
うっすが違いがあるくらいですでなあなあ軌道の撮影で僕はね中心になったわけでまだ
体がしんどいんですけどいなー夏は外出るとき気を付けられないって言うんで今日はで
ほどかわいい
動きですね今回はこちらとソーダーストリームジェネシスデラックススターターキッ
インクルーズ飲み物を炭酸にするような奴なんですよね通称だねちょっと冷たいものを
たくさん飲みたいわけなんですよ google かんあそうだメーカー取れそうだ
メーカーっていうのはあっという間に出来上がります層増税の必要もありません毎日
定格区で炭酸飲料を解くお得ら
とりあえずれがあればなんか炭酸飲料を貼っすぐ作れるみたいな
御札を思う覚えよ価値の音じゃこれを船や早いガス部活動名が入ってます藪ないなぁ
導出所今日は実際にこの炭酸飲料はこの相談メイクを作っいろんなどういうものを炭酸
飲料にしていこうと思ってますでもねそんなにうまくいくと俺もうごっつねだからなぁ
髪の毛伸びたら次は今日朝てくれず設定したっっ悪さしますチャー頃するっは
pa
脇田してからこれでいいのもしこれで多分大丈夫だボタンみたいなのないんもんなん
ですけど怖いよ田園とがない感じで5
あっ待ってもう
あっ
きてる感じで本多分実際片付で天井でこれさぁ卓といろんなものを炭酸にしていき
ましょう
かき氷のシロップとかねこんな場合レートただのかき氷のアズがする弱まったり
ジュースになるんだがなんとなんと思う
炭酸を入れるとは美味しい炭酸ジュースになるという話をしました
とりあえずねかき氷炭酸辞書を作ろうた頭は良くても色があっ
これをちょっとた炭酸にしてみましょう僕は心配や本当にできるか
あっうんっ
[音楽]
おえなにこれうわあああっもってこい爆発
待って大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫だこれ
a これコースれてなんかプシューってなんだ
[音楽]
うわーうわー
でも炭酸こいつをターン3ターンは出ていますこれ本当にできたらすごいよ
飲んでみましょうなるほどなく言ってやると炭酸がちゃんと
導入される飲んでみます
モンスターベアのなんかあるの味になります
ほらあのモンスターとがレッドブルとがオロナミン c とか bob ダンデーとか
なぁそういう栄養剤チックたちに変わりましたこれでびっくりだ
団扇って佐藤卓さん減ってな多分どんな行ってみよう挨拶件牛乳をやってみましょう
あなたの牛乳だって作ったこともないしいろんな事もないんで生まれとき興味本意感が
ありますね
スペイン努力を
おいしい水よりは好きなんだけどこいつを炭酸にしたときにどういう味になるかという
のが一気になるよね伊勢市はファイヤ
なってなんか大丈夫かあふれるちょ待ったんだなんだ姿んだ
大丈夫よこれちょっとして牛乳ダメなのかな
[音楽]
[拍手]
saas 族が出てきての前まで来てまた鮭流してんだけどちょっと邪魔なんで何でも
リヤドをつくっちゃう作りたいんだろ
さーああああっ
[音楽]
待って絶対おかしいでしょマテ待てマテ待てません招いてちょっとなパワーますが第3
図じゃねーか
ん
[音楽]
刺激的にまずい打つ気普通にお茶お茶の炭酸まで見たことないってどこまでごその炭酸
っていうのはで美味しいかどうか今回明らかになりますぞ
よし
なんだいつもこれちゃうんだけどお茶の炭酸ですただのションベンさせる飲んでみ
ましょう
[音楽]
これは姉は最後はちょっとねここを使って新しい何カップもやって射精にコーラで
ください33を抜かないように行ってみましょうこれがしたいのはあれだ
すでに炭酸が入っているものにさらに炭酸を付け足すとどうなるか炭酸かける炭酸で
ひょっとしたらどんどんおねっといただけます炭酸2のは二酸化炭素が入ってるわけだ
から
下手すると43が単線っていうソ
て爆発しないよね白髪だけは山名いきます
うわぁ大丈夫かなぁ猫はいますなってちょいやー
[音楽]
tee
ちょっと弱まった
[音楽]
tes
e 7